[Music]
megan starts off this hour in charlotte
north carolina hi megan how are you
i'm all right thanks so much for taking
my call dave and george how are you guys
today better than we deserve what's up
in your world
well
my husband passed away nine weeks ago oh
my unexpectedly
yes and i am
he had a heart attack in the middle of
the night oh my lord how old was he
um i'm 31 he's 50. he was 50 i guess
wow
oh my goodness i'm so sorry
thank you yeah so we have two very small
children two years old and nine months
old
and
i'm just terrified i listen to you all
the time i'm a huge fan and i just
wanted to know
what advice you have for me what
mistakes do you see people make in this
situation and and what do i need to do i
just i'm at a loss
what decisions are you needing to make
right now
well the life insurance which thankfully
we had um just came in yesterday
so
um need to decide what to do with that
and
decide what to do
that's 800
800 okay
and do you have a house
yes i have a house that um
i can't stand right now as you can
imagine
so
and what is it worth
it's worth about 700 we owe about 400 on
it okay
all right
so let me kind of give you a general
principle that we all use here
um and then we can back in out of that
and into that for you know you and i can
to you and i and george can to figure
out what your best
some of your best ideas are okay
um
when you go through something like this
particularly something that is um
when you go through losing someone
particularly suddenly and tragically
unexpectedly it
uh
your brain uh
no one's brain
uh functions at full capacity in the
middle of heavy
grief
okay
and so uh you got this fog i mean sharon
i've been married 40 years if uh
something happened to sharon my brain
wouldn't work good for a while you know
what i'm saying
and so um it doesn't mean it doesn't
mean i'm dumb it doesn't mean i have a
bad brain it just means that in the
middle of uh this kind of trauma
uh is the worst possible time to make
major decisions if you can avoid making
major decisions is that logical
yes so for instance um
i wouldn't go on some kind of big
campaign to become a professional
investor with 800 000 right now you're
31 years old with two little babies
and you're you know
you you know and
you said this horrible thing happened
and so i i always tell people if you can
let's just put that in the cd and park
it for six months and cry
okay
all right i'm not making any decisions
for six months i'm just gonna cry and
let the fog of grief
go by
because uh grief comes and waves i mean
you'll be going along with everything's
fine they'll say they just hit you right
some silly smell or noise or something
that you know triggers your brain
triggers a memory and it just hits you
and you don't even see it coming and
that you know you don't want to make a
800 000 investment decision in the
middle of that so
if you can let's do nothing
okay that's first thing now doing
nothing is not possible because you got
to eat keep the lights on
you've got to figure out you know do you
have an income do you work
i've taken leave from work since this
has happened okay what were you doing
um i was a personal assistant okay and
what were you making
um 65. okay he was the breadwinner
okay
all right and if you if you make
decisions
um
let's try to make decisions that can be
undone
okay let me give you an example
okay
it might be okay to sell the house
if you want out if you just can't stand
the place right now i take it he passed
away at home
yeah in our bed yeah
and so just walking around that house is
icky
right that's what you're saying i can't
stand this house that's what you said
yeah
so it's okay
to move however moving is emotionally
traumatic too
two babies dadgum right
everything you do is emotionally
dramatic
but
um but i i don't think i would go buy a
700 000 house today
so if i did anything i would just sell
and go find something to rent and you
know it's my crying spot for six months
or a year i'm gonna sit here for a year
and then later i'm gonna make a decision
on where i want to live
okay but i don't think you're
i i would not be
in the state of mind to make a decision
on where i want to live for the next
five years
right so if you want to dump the house
that's something that the only downside
of that is you can't get that house back
right but you can get another house
later
um if you just go okay the chances of me
wanting to live here five years from now
is almost zero and the chances of me
want to live here five days from now is
zero so i'm done with this thing we're
tapping out on it
so now i don't have 800
now i got a million two to sit in a cd
while i just rent and go back to work
and pay my bills or pull enough off the
million two
to quit your job and start a new job
a year from now and just set aside a
salary set aside a hundred thousand
bucks to live on for a year
okay okay but what you don't want to get
into then is grief
spending which is medicating the pain
with buying stuff
so you set yourself on a
like you like you say okay here's an
amount of money i'm not going to touch
like if we did that if we sold the house
and you said you got 400 000 equity
right yes okay plus 800 is a million too
following me
yes sir your rent
you don't have any other debt right
nothing okay
and you just you just put yourself in
park mode
so you can heal
give yourself some margin to heal
and then a year from today
we decide what you you decide what your
career is a year from today based on
your new career you decide what house
you want to buy
okay
and you say out of that million two i'm
gonna set aside a hundred thousand over
here and i'm that's gonna be my salary
eight thousand dollars a month
for
one year and i have no payments except a
rent payment
that makes sense
yes it does and you don't touch the
other million one for anything
don't tell me don't tell me you found
something in the middle of your grief
that you have to do because there's no
such
thing
follow me
because i've seen people burn through
this and and i've seen them make dumb
decisions
trying to be
stiff upper lip
trying to be strong
in a time when you don't shouldn't even
be trying to be strong you should just
cry move slow and just grieve yeah
so sorry megan yeah it's awful